[Music]
edgar is contemplating life right now
very deeply look at him
uh what the is this map oh god we
we reduced the vision a little bit i
like that actually
all right we're both doing this one
there we go
what's happened
so i
normally oh god two so i went on vitals
and saw that joel was dead and then i
pressed the i started looking around but
i was like i don't wait there's vitals
in this game well now we can't find the
body though because
yeah i was to wonder i was going to ask
if anyone has seen joel or
shawn around i saw a bunch of people in
near the comms pewds was there and jaden
was that yes listen jade no and not
jaden actually i saw dave for a second
it was just above it where was the body
did not see the body no there was nobody
i don't know all right let's find the
body
they can destroy the body
when dating called the meeting it clears
it so that we can't see them on the map
anymore
yeah jayden i wanted to stop it before
the their cooldowns refreshed
she said like she's on like four sets
[Music]
oh my god
that was fast wow what the hell
crazy i just want to kill lizzy every
time first because if she survives
it seems fair
all right let's do this easy
all right we close the doors there maybe
yeah
he says christ i get jump scared every
time
somebody killing me wait who reportedly
anyway i i reported it i didn't actually
see it i just was looking around for the
body what's this news and i couldn't see
it wait a minute wait i don't understand
is there new settings where you can't
see the body sometimes it kind of
glitches though i i walked down and i
saw the button like light up so i ran
back and pressed in
dave apparently was doing the same thing
the lights were off and then i saw the
report thing and as the lights came on i
still couldn't see the body did you see
anyone around like on your screen
why didn't you press the report button i
was trying to see where the body was
before i did it because i knew everyone
would be saying where was the ball
how big is the general like vicinity of
where you can report it like i don't
know i feel as long as you see it
in corpse you were the only other one
around there
no we all just ran from the top for the
fact that you're pushing
this
i don't know i'm skipping
[Music]
i'm just playing the game as i would
play i don't know what liz's game is uh
we're both trying to wait for people to
come this way should i go ben
all right i'm doing it i've never done
this before
that's it it just goes here or there
all right if anyone asked i was in
weapons clearing asteroids okay weapons
clearing asteroids uh i went to lab to
align the telescope and then i headed
back
and i headed back to go to weapons
where is everyone
what is happening
i went
i'm getting locked in i i'm supposed to
be the one oh god oh i think pj saw me
that's very suspicious i'm gonna have to
kill him
oh okay jaden's there that was close
that was so close oh i locked myself in
i thought that was to attract someone
here where i can never get anyone alone
all right they're all here oh that's
good
oh sh it this ice mcstable lighters
lizzy just murdered the out
of somebody right in front of me
it was you and then i just replied
also i have other information um i think
felix is also guilty because i saw him
trying to do the asteroids because i
just did the asteroids it takes ages he
was at the company i was i wasn't in the
weapons because that's not what i was
doing felix also came to the scanner and
didn't do anything and then that's
literally what it was i was doing the
lab getting samples thank you very much
i'm kind of suspicious okay
i i also agree with felix oh it doesn't
tell us you agreed that i was doing it
or what no no no no liar oh okay all
right well i guess uh
stinky's gonna have to die
the all the doors are locked all
the time
oh perfect
bonnie right near the emergency yeah you
suspect me now pj huh all right yeah
i was with felix and yeah
yeah
yeah i apologize it could be dave
i think it's dave i thought it was felix
before but i you are you doubt
wait wait wait what do we do what are we
doing
i don't know man but if if we voted
wrong we lose that's why i wasn't sure
oh no wait does that mean
oh god don't kill me
nice nice one lizzy well done my
i was at the god ready to push it but
the lights were out and i couldn't and i
was trying to dodge him so much you
called me right away
uh i think it's felix i was like why
i didn't do anything he was really
sticking up for lisa there for a second
[Laughter]
[Applause]
felix just so you know the next time i
suspect you i'm not backing down
i'm killing them you backed me up
that was great what happened we're
killing lizzy first turn i moved through
the vents that's how i got to you all
right dave is my alibi
you're not muted
well then you know i'm safe
he's going with me now that's so funny
dave come here oh god lights please
please i'm scared uh this is when i die
okay edward's fixed where the was
that dj let's check him
i can confirm ken corps and lizzy all
did the med bay scan
wait where is where was the body where
was the body it's down in that what's
the bottom right area
there's like two buildings there's two
rooms like stuck together
through the decontamination doors yeah
the place where you see the vitals i
think joel is safe i fixed the lights
twice
and then i ran down and i found her body
down there in that room i was following
felix at the start and then i just saw
people scanning so i checked them out pj
what you've been up to i've just been
doing tasks on the left side uh i was at
the bottom for a while because i was
doing the asteroids one right at the
bottom doing the asteroid oh on the left
yeah yeah okay
we can
ken just trying to find it from ken
please come here from ken joel
i don't think i can vote for anyone
right now personally but yeah
we're just gonna ignore what felix said
when he was on mutator yeah
is dave gonna kill me
i think i actually think these boys are
safe
unless both of them are killers
this is a cool area i never go here
yeah
where no
oh guess it's not jill it's not sure
okay two people are dead i i suspect
jack for no other reason oh
thank you i i fixed things three times i
went up and did the thing on the line i
definitely think it's jack
why i hear you lying feeling yeah i
feel it
i've been doing tests
voting felix
yeah because it's you and you're trying
to turn it around no i'm just turning on
you because you're really suspicious and
you're turning it on me
[Music]
okay
all right all right you'll regret this
get him in there
i hear he's lying bro
well it was jack
baby
i know you're lying voice i know it
you i did it against it
it seems like i don't have a good poker
face in front of felix it was me
i swear
that's jack's turn or the reactors go
off screen sorry
damn that was bad oh my god joel dies
immediately every single someone's out
for bloody stinky at the top of the map
straight away yeah lizzy and dave were
here and i don't know which one it was
all right
jack was here no
[Music]
i was on my way out and i came back to
watch what dave was doing and then he
walked up in a dead body wait where was
it where were you right it's right and
spawn lizzy and stinky were both at the
top with the body and i walked up to
them so he's
the key uh dialogue yeah i did the key
thing uh dave who do you vote for i was
still in it when they were allowed
probably neither of them reported the
body wait sorry they could have been in
the middle i didn't see it because i was
doing the cave it was there yeah and you
left and i had left and then you were
there and i went back in with you yeah
it's jack
i don't i don't think it's i don't think
it's jack i don't think it's jackie yeah
i think this was right last time so
believe him this time wait dave reported
it though dave yeah i reported it
because neither of you two did
i love that reporting a potty is like
okay for you to get killed at that point
like
oh you found it you're dead you know
what i should do if i play real 4d chess
whenever i'm not guilty i should do some
very distinct things like overly accuse
everyone so then when i stop doing it
they'll think
i'm the opposite right distinctly
characteristics
[Music]
oh i thought he killed me jesus where is
he where is he where is he i came up to
do the turn off the thing and he was
dead next to it oh my god okay well i
was with pj masks
lizzie and jaden's hands are clear where
was jaden oh was she
wait why are they
corpse could have killed me and he
didn't
wait
and it was an electrical did you say no
it was up at the reactor thingy it was
like right next to that uh the most left
oh i just turned off the thing
oh he's doing the lying thing
we won't actually know if it was him
either someone come with me to the
scanner someone come with me to the
scanner i'm gonna say if she walks
towards me i'm reporting her right away
no
oh
it's pb and jaden isn't it those
okay corpse is safe stay recorded
i'll definitely murder now
oh my god i found a buddy
how did you find a dumb body in this
darkness very serious yeah
some people two people ran ahead of me
and i'm not sure who it was oh you're
not sure
i watched him scan then lizzy pj and
felix all ran past
lizzie when where when did i was running
from med bay to the lights
no i was doing the lights and i was with
jayden
she wasn't in the same room but i saw
her uh yeah
yeah i was following you guys and pete
all right lucy are you lying also jaden
uh and me fixed the hand print thing
where you need two people so i still
don't suspect no i did the reactor on
the left i watched you do it pj but i
was scared so i stayed on the i was
scared as well but i we trusted each
other we both did it with our hands so
it's either lizzie or felix i kind of
think i was like
yeah and pewds ran off in the opposite
direction i don't know where he was was
he at the right hand side reactor with
you i was in the garden area or whatever
the it's called
wait i'm trying to remember if i saw
felix go back into the lab because
that's where corpse was i wasn't back in
the live was outside i think it's huge
okay it's definitely you then what is
that
yeah no yeah oh
okay pj listen
you're done
jaden stay with me i don't trust okay
this is a tricky one huh all right
all right all right something's got to
happen pj i don't think it's pj he would
have killed me there if you had the
chance um you were also making no effort
to go and help fix the lights no i know
yeah cause i was scared i was scared and
i couldn't see any light thing all right
it's still cool down though so couldn't
you guys have killed each other if you
wanted to well i don't know we didn't
really find anything out this round
she she accused me and i'm 100 innocent
pewds last round had like called who it
was right at the end of the round and
then calls an emergency meeting straight
away when we have no new influence no i
do that all the time that's a regular
thing it's four people left we have to
vote otherwise it's out no we don't have
to vote there's only one person we don't
know that if there's only one left how
did would you know wait wait wait wait
wait wait jaden how do you jaden how do
you only know there's only one oh yeah
you're right that's right because if
that's just how the game works you're
right you're right all right fair fair
fair i think it's lazy i'm voting lucy i
just got it
i'm gonna
follow
one person okay let's all go together
let's all look at it yeah okay
it's nice
that's not all together
all right follow me let me do one task
felix your instinct was totally right
it's lizzy oh my god i'm gonna be so
much buttering up his ego so he votes
for who you want my ego
you're done how dare you insult my ego
and my character trying to praise you
[Applause]
bye
get her off the ship
it's
[Laughter]
i
was shocked jade was like an amateur
move to kill at the reactor i was like i
know
lizzy i'm sorry i made that so hard on
you
let's go poggers don't all right kick
kill jack whoever's the killer please
yeah yeah let's let's kill wait what the
is this i'll protect kang guys
you're all alone okay protect him you're
not getting away
if we're protected
we're bodyguards
come on ken
where'd he go yo ken where oh okay
finally
oh that was a lot of fun i nearly
finished my tasks i found this
um i was around jaden for a long time
and she didn't do anything to me yeah
clearly no one's done anything to anyone
okay doesn't mean anything someone's
really nervous afraid to murder i watch
kids do the scanner yes thank you i'm
saying the person that saw me do the
scanner was william who is now dead but
i did do it and that's why
william is that true he was there with
liz
it is true
i saw corpse and somebody else i didn't
see the name when i did the reactor
thingy on the left i'm just saying not a
lot of people are dead and ken was afk
for a long time
oh
good point
yeah i was but then i lost i lost him he
left before someone found the body you
left me
it would make sense we should just do
all our tasks and win yeah
okay pj i have mid-day by the way
watch me do med batteries
i protected you how
so i follow you this whole game no one
dies and then you leave he's gonna kill
me for that ain't going with him no
don't kill me no please please don't do
it
no i'm sorry
don't do it save me show me thank you oh
thank god you guys
all right what's happening no one's
dying
you're pressing the button
i have a slight suspicion of pj yeah
me too oh i haven't seen him i was
getting vibes
uh i saw jaden do the uh med scan um
does does william know that he can do
tasks while he's dead he's muted hey i'm
almost done with my task are you where
are you guys done my mine's all done
i think it's pj and ken well william has
to do his task and we don't know if he
can hear us oh he's deafened in the oh
pj can i are you in your bad vibes
yeah i did see him on campus kind of
just running around yeah you were doing
a lot of running around
i'm voting pda
oh my god guys they're the kids i'm just
gonna play devil's advocate because i
like entertainment i'm voting
[Laughter]
jack are you guilty no i've been
following you to see if you were guilty
oh god
that's the two killers right there
what do i do
really in front of everyone all right
no i was separated so i could i knew
exactly this was gonna happen group
kills are so smart and only you would
pull it uh i i okay i did pull it last
time and it didn't work
and i'll never try it again
and the fact that hayden is so
accusatory of me joel
what how did it how did he get away with
that that was in front of everyone i am
so upset if this ever happens during
real life i will become a ghost and hunt
you and it's a no it's annoying me so
much yeah it was ken he didn't see it
did he ken was there i've done all my
tasks is this something i thought there
might be a body there i think it's sean
who went to the left what shawn and pj
i'm so mad everyone else
i mean yeah none of us lizzie didn't do
it jaden didn't do it
like the bottom of the map why did jaden
report it if she i'm so confused i
i hate how i don't know who the killer
is we were four people because i would
hack williams computer and do his tasks
okay toast boy roomie stinky and jaden
was there literally four people and then
jaden who reported it corpse reported it
why did corpse reported it you freaking
fricks oh they're all waiting there for
william to do the task
i just don't know who the other one is
there we go jack again it's ken yeah
so that means jaden yeah jaden was there
so it's jason
i definitely can definitely can what
about johnny that's so suspicious why
were you standing there after you killed
her as well i voted ken right away too
who who's that
uh ken you have to vote um you can vote
for yourself if you want if you do feel
the guilt
i don't i don't have to do anything i
can just sit here oh wait
it was murdered in front of
oh i wonder who it is jack's getting
better
i still i still hear his voice oh my god
please
look at the task dude who hasn't done it
at this point
please there's everything he's chasing
me
oh my god lucy are you sorry
if i was chasing you i would have killed
you a long time
somebody else died right or was it just
yeah tops cops died which means it's
jack
yes please jack
what were you doing
let me just start the next round please
you were just like accusing us even
though it would have worked i'm
very paranoid we would have gotten away
with it if it wasn't for your kids my
god
if i could help you i would all i could
do was sabotage
my best to kill everyone the two most
passive people
i think you and me we just have this
thing where we want to kill each other
no matter what now it doesn't matter it
doesn't have anything to do with the
game i was right i knew it was you
and jaden
they killed me in front of you you said
nothing
we were four people wait barry is still
level one oh
and you haven't fed bob
goddamn sickness
because their new trials mode is like
use your full pixeling ruses to defeat
as many enemy waves as possible download
pixel links instantly for 20
muscle increase oh